but the companies do say they will scale
up the program if it is successful guys
very cool we love it will thank you it's
a bird it's a plane its Superman son on
TV without pants very cool we love it
will thank you let's rewind shall we on
Tuesday we'll read a reporter for ABC
and the son of the late Christopher
Reeve thanks TV
yeah like Superman Clark Kent
Christopher Reeve appeared on Good
Morning America from his home to talk
about well who the hell knows what he
was talking about because all anyone
could pay attention to was the fact that
he was on national TV
Sam's pants but the companies do say
they will scale up the program if it is
successful guys very cool we love it
will thank you yep that's well rockin a
colored shirt and jacket up top and
short shorts on the bottom first rule of
zoom guys if you're gonna go pantless
always always check your camera angle
but the companies do say they will scale
up the program if it is successful guys
very cool we love it will thank you
it's the mullet about fit business up
top party on the bottom and if we're
being honest who can't relate to this
right now naturally the whole thing went
viral and our pantsless dude handled the
embarrassment like a champ tweeting this
screenshot and writing I have arrived in
the most hilariously mortifying way
possible will explained what happened in
a separate post he was just trying to be
efficient getting ready for his workout
before he went on TV he says he won't
make the same mistake again but really
will don't worry you're not alone in
going pantless on TV this is the first
time I've been on easy with no pants on
and the thing is it's so comfortable and
it's so great yeah that's how we mendel
chatting it up with ET manzai on full
display you just gotta look okay and
then from the top up yeah look at me yes
I'm just enjoying I have I'm not wearing
I'm just naked from the waist down but
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
all in this together yes yes look at my
knees on TV no you're on Sumi you could
pick anything
[Music]